c'est une résidence qui se réveille
abassourdi d'une nuit cauchemardesque en
quelques heures une dispute conjugale
vire au drame familial et plonge le
voisinage aux premières loges de
l'effroi michel a tenté de recueillir
les laits de cette fratrie de quatre
enfants âgés de 13 ans poursuivi par un
beau-père déterminé à le tuer quitte à
s'introduire violemment dont le domicile
de son voisin
j'ai du sang dans toutes les pièces de
la maison ma porte est cassé des forces
et bien entendu du sang dans toutes les
pièces de la maison quand même très
impressionnant
sa petite soeur m'a dit que ça faisait
deux mois qu il était après lui donc
c'est enfin sans fin bien compris son
père ou laitue puisqu'il venait déjà de
blesser gravement sa mère gravement sa
mère au crâne au visage à l'oreille il
dans le coup de plus dans le coup de le
coup de casser et donc il savait très
bien que
il n'avait qu'une alternative c'est de
fuir une fuite qui se poursuit c'est un
autre voisin en contrebas et c'est sur
cette barrière qui a cédé sous le choc
que la course poursuite acharnée de ce
militaire de carrière s'est achevée
grâce à l'intervention musclée et
solidaire des voisins le voisin fermer
la grille et c'est à ce moment là que je
les jeux les plaqués contre la grille et
que sa tête a tapé ça l'a un peu étourdi
sa tête a tapé contre la grille et on
est partis tous les deux ans en faisant
une espèce de boule et après je lui ai
fait une clé de bras et le voisin mis
son pied sur le sur le coutelas et ont
la maîtrise et on a pu neutraliser cet
individu et dieu merci les voisins ont
été tous coopératif parce qu'il avait le
coutelas grand même main donc il fallait
être faire très attention et on va dire
l'attaqué au moment où il était le plus
fine et la cua en parallèle la mère de
famille elle aussi en fuite est
gravement blessé à la tête à la gorge et
au poignet a eu la chance d'être prise
en charge par un médecin résident dans
le quartier
j'ai des compresses pansements absorbant
j'ai des choses comme ça on est descendu
qu'on a cherché on a essayé de faire
l'hémostase des plaies de bourg et la
plaie du coup en particulier et puis
heureusement les secours médicaux sont
arrivés rapidement avec un médecin très
calme qui a très bien pris les choses en
main depuis plus de deux mois
cette résidence est tout le quartier
d'acajou est privé d'eau une carence qui
pourrait être la cause de cet excès de
violence
cette dame était excédé donc avec quatre
enfants le mari aller chercher de l'eau
tous les jours donc c'était je pense que
ça y est aussi pour beaucoup d'autres
moi je voulais encore attiré l'attention
de toute la martinique sur ces problèmes
d'eau l'auteur des faits a été placé en
garde à vue dans l'attenté d'une
comparution immédiate
sa femme et son beau fils ont été pris
en charge par le chu leur pronostic
vital n'est pas engagé quant aux
résidents entre la pénurie d'eau et ce
fait divers il aspire aujourd'hui à un
peu d'évasion